І.
Квантові комп'ютери дуже чутливі до шуму —
збурень, що спричиняють помилки
в їхніх обчисленнях. Але нове дослідження показує,
що зашумлені квантові комп'ютери IBM відповідають точним класичним методам
і перевіряють режими, де класичні наближені
методи справляються в обох — верифікованому
та неверифікованому — режимах
для складного симуляційного експерименту.
Як їм це вдається? Вони використовують особливу техніку
для боротьби з шумом
у квантових системах — вона називається пом'якшення помилок.
За допомогою техніки пом'якшення помилок,
використаної в цьому експерименті, ми запускаємо обчислення
і поступово підвищуємо рівень шуму.
Потім ми екстраполюємо назад до нульового рівня шуму.
Ця робота наближає нас на один крок до корисних квантових обчислень —
ми